cette nouvelle loi française pousse de
plus en plus d'influenceurs à quitter
Dubaï Nabilla jazz Dylan Thierry ils
étaient nombreux à s'être exilés dans
cette eldorado des Émirats arabes unis à
la fiscalité avantageuse mais les rêves
de gloire et de richesse facile se
heurte désormais à une nouvelle réalité
la régulation par l'état du système de
placement de produit a mis un terme à
une pratique lucrative mais au
nombreuses dérives résultat cette
technique marketing qui consiste à faire
la promotion d'un produit via un
influenceur a vu ses tarifs s'effondrer
les marques qui proposaient hier jusqu'à
2000 euros par placement sur Instagram
ne sont prêtes à en débourser que 300 en
moyenne aujourd'hui la réputation d'une
partie des influenceurs a aussi été
affectée par la politique du name and
shame engagé depuis quelques mois par le
ministère des Finances elle consiste à
épingler publiquement certains
influenceurs qui s'adonneraient à des
pratiques commerciales trompeuses cette
loi arrive comme un coup de massue
supplémentaire pour les influenceurs
issus de la téléréalité dont l'audience
s'essouffle même les finalistes des
émissions de téléréalité ne parviennent
plus à attirer sur les réseaux sociaux
au même moment les loyers déjà très
élevés à Dubaï ont flambé de 27% l'an
passé une première vague d'influenceurs
commencent à quitter les miracles pour
s'installer en Thaïlande en Indonésie ou
encore au Maroc les pays où l'on paie
moins d'impôts qu'en France et où la vie
est moins chère d'autres comme Nicolas
lozina ou 1,9 millions d'abonnés sur
Instagram OPT pour un retour au pays moi
je n'ai aucun problème à dire que les
temps ont changé je ne travaille plus
avec l'agence Shauna events je n'ai donc
plus de travail
[Musique]